oui
les feux de forêt contenues dans les
alpes-maritimes mais l'année dernière
après la lure d'un cauchemar pour un
millier de vacanciers
le scandale du carrefour du
développement après les accusations d'
yves chalier les personnalités mises en
cause ce contre attaque
l' amorce de fernand pouillon l'histoire
retiendra l'architecte de talent sans
s'arrêter sur le scandale qui brisa sa
carrière
ce vendredi 25 juillet voici quatre cent
quatre-vingt dix jours que marcel carton
et marcel fontaine sont détenus 429
jours que sont détenus jean paul
kauffmann et michel seurat 139 jours
pour nos amis aurel cornéa et jean louis
normandin 79 jours pour camille sontag
il y a toujours sept otages français
détenus au liban
madame monsieur bonsoir chaque été c'est
la même chose on dit que ça ne peut pas
durer que ça ne va pas durer il faut
faire quelque chose on va faire quelque
chose et pourtant chaque été c'est
pareil des milliers d'hectares de forêts
disparaissent en fumée
la nuit dernière on est même passé à
deux doigts de la vraie catastrophe dans
les alpes-maritimes ravagé par le feu
puisque 15 cents personnes ont dû être
évacuées
elle était pourtant portes de nice et de
monaco il y à un mort peut être deux et
des renforts ont dû être acheminés de la
région parisienne
voyez le reportage de riz bodiguel et de
maryse richard ils sont arrivés sur les
lieux c'était au petit jour sur la
partie du littoral situé entre nice et
monaco jamais les incendies n'avait
atteint une telle ampleur est revêtue
pareil caractère dramatique des
incendies il y en a chaque année mais
toujours localisé est relativement
facile à cerner cette nuit un vent assez
violent n'a jamais cessé de souffler et
en attisant les flammes
il a multiplié les foyers du même coup
les pompiers et les sauveteurs n'ont
jamais été en mesure de maîtriser tous
les foyers au fur et à mesure qu'il se
développait à cap d'ail ou une station
service était menacée et as où les
flammes sont parvenus jusqu'aux villages
on a frôlé la catastrophe
il fallait d'ailleurs que la situation
fut dramatique pour que dans la vallée
du paillon près de nice
on fit sonner le tocsin pendant toute la
nuit mais c'est un ace que la situation
était la plus critique et certains
habitants avaient ce matin tout perdu
mêlant sortait de tous les pores qu'on
n'en voulez vous qu'ils fassent ces
hommes enlevés le bord
je pourrais bornes tout le monde
été le sujet de ma rue et les ponts
bière sur la tête avec le vent qui la
veille avait surtout plein le mistral
avec une force inouïe les habits de deux
qui part de la propreté de la colline et
venait à me lever ici le ce n'est pas le
fait que les partis dit-il escarbilles
qui venait de derrière la colline qui
ont mis le feu dans ces termes c'est
tout chèque là dedans
le plus révoltant c'est que plusieurs
incendies ont une origine criminelle
c'était en tout cas ce matin la
conviction de nombreux sauveteurs qui
avaient lutté toute la nuit malgré le
danger
plusieurs d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs été
blessés et plusieurs personnes ont dû
être évacuées après avoir été
intoxiquées par la fumée
oui nous verrons tout à l'heure avec
leurs embouts sied si le vent menace
toujours la région mais ce soir je peux
vous dire que les pompiers redoutent en
tout cas en ce moment une reprise des
foyers en france toujours les vagues du
scandale dans la sphère du carrefour du
développement dans le figaro magazine à
paraître demain yves chalier le
principal accusé cette affaire mais très
abondamment pose plusieurs personnalités
politiques de premier plan des
personnalités qui engage ce soir
la contre attaque jean-michel mercurol
christian nucci d'abord il sut allier
prétend qu'il n'y a pas eu imitation de
la signature du ministre christian nucci
ce signe est il signer n'importe quoi
dit il
il n'y a pas eu de faux autre
affirmation des chevaliers carrefour du
développement à financer la campagne
d'affichage du candidat nucci dans
l'isère riposte aujourd'hui le christian
nucci
il y a bien eu falsification de sa
signature et carrefour du développement
n'a nullement financer sa campagne
électorale
christian nucci voit dans cette affaire
une opération politique avec laquelle on
cherche à atteindre d'autres
personnalités du ps
autre personnalité citée par yves
chalier l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale louis mermaz lui
aussi aurait financé ses affiches
électorales par le carrefour du
développement
réponse de louis mermaz ni lui ni la
fédération du ps de l'isère non passer
aucune commande à quelqu'un prémery de
beaurepaire que ce soit il a déposé
plainte
aujourd'hui alain poher enfin il a été
cité paris scellier
une affaire d'association africaines
victimes de malversations financières
mises au point aujourd'hui du président
du sénat ceci n'a rien à voir avec
carrefour du développement
les malversations ont été découvertes
après le décès du coupable
par devoir moral en tant que président
de l'association alain poher a jugé bon
de veiller personnellement à l'apurement
des comptes de l'association
la mort d'hubert dubedout l'ancien
député maire de grenoble ils étaient en
train de gravir le mont blanc avec
quelques amis lorsqu'il a été terrassé
sans doute par une crise cardiaque
il avait 63 ans et grenoble lui doit
d'être devenue l'une des grandes villes
d'europe d'ailleurs amusé l'adversaire
ne s'y sont pas trompés en lui rendant
un hommage unanime
aujourd'hui estelle gouzy nous
rappellent qu'ils étaient hubert
dubedout hubert dubedout n'était pas un
homme politique comme les autres
il aurait pu faire une carrière
nationale mais il a préféré se consacrer
entièrement à sa ville
grenoble une municipalité qui l'avait
conquise en 1965 et conserver jusqu aux
élections municipales de 83 sa défaite
face aux chiraquiens alain carignon
avait d'ailleurs surpris
il lui rend pourtant aujourd'hui le plus
bel hommage en déclarant grenoble et
triste il est vrai qu hubert dubedout
s'était littéralement identifié à
grenoble il avait réussi ce qu'il
souhaitait pour elle en faire une ville
phare les jeux olympiques de 1968 en
furent la consécration
depuis il avait abandonné toute activité
politique
âgé de 63 ans marié père de deux enfants
ce grenoblois de coeur était aussi un
amoureux de la montagne
il y a trouvé la mort une sacrée
bataille d'experts en perspective dans
la sphère de la rue de mogador
l'identité judiciaire vient de
communiquer son rapport balistique on
espérait qu'il permettrait d'établir
avec certitude les circonstances dans
laquelle loïc lefebvre été abattu mais
des certitudes il n'y en a pas dans ce
rapport en tout cas rien de déterminant
sur la situation sur la position
le hic fort bien été atteinte par deux
projectiles
l'un d'eux a pénétré dans le dos un peu
à gauche pour en sortir par l'avant du
thorax un peu à droite loïc lefebvre
était donc alors légèrement de trois
quarts dos par rapport aux crs gilbert
bourse l'autre a transpercé la main
gauche arrachant de doux
avec le faire on était un peu plus de
profils semble-t-il l'une des deux
balles à traverser l'avant bras droit
sans que l'on puisse dire laquelle il y
a donc quand dans l'instant qui sépare
les deux tirs une légère rotation de la
victime mais on ne peut dire dans quel
sens on ne peut en effet affirmé
laquelle des deux bâle a été tiré la
première
une chose est sûre loïc lefebvre ne
pouvait faire face à son poursuivant au
moment du drame
comme le prétendent et gilles burgos qui
est d'ailleurs revenu sur ses premières
déclarations il est impossible de dire
ce qui explique la rotation de la
victime entre les deux impacts le
mouvement d'un homme qui court le choc
du premier tir l'intention de se
retourner dans un geste menaçant à peine
esquissée par ailleurs la bombe
lacrymogène ont trouvé sur place planté
bien des traces de sang du groupe à
auquel appartient loïc lefebvre
première hypothèse la bombe était bien
dans la main du jeune homme au moment du
coup de feu deuxième hypothèse la bande
aurait été perdu par une prostituée dans
la confusion qui a suivi le drame et
serait tombé dans la flaque de sang
il n'est pas tout à fait impossible
qu'un geste du fuyard et pu faire croire
aux policiers qu'il était menacé
rien ne permet pourtant jusqu'ici la
qualité sérieusement la thèse de la
légitime défense
3 blessé deux passants et un policier
lors da rold pas paris une course
poursuite entre policiers gangster une
fusillade et donc ce bilan l'un des
malfaiteurs a été interpellé un espoir
et philippe menut se sont immédiatement
rendus sur les lieux
tout s'est passé en quelques minutes au
début de l'après midi une dizaine de
personnes attendant cette agence du
crédit mutuel à côté du sacré coeur
quand deux malfaiteurs armés à la main
quand irruption dans la banque
non je prenais mon argent j'attendais
l'argent de laquelle ils sont arrivés
par derrière de chanter dessus ils ont
ils ont bousculé tout le monde en fait
les mutualités n'étaient que 2 et
on sait tous ce calme et enfin les gens
l'abandon était parfait et ils sont
partis dans son parti de à l'extérieur
et moi j'aurais courru après dans la rue
en poussant des cris pour qu'on les
arrête
mais arrivée sur le boulevard devant ce
cinéma une fusillade éclate entre les
malfaiteurs et une brigade de policiers
en civil un policier s'écroule
grièvement blessée au poumon
le serveur du restaurant tout proche est
touché à l'épaule les deux hommes
traqués monte dans ce bus et menace le
chauffeur et tous les passagers
l'autobus démarre une passagère est
blessé aux jambes et les malfaiteurs
s'enfuient au volant d'une 4l volé mes
policiers les prennent en chasse pendant
qu'on évacue le brigadier de laisser un
peu plus tard alors que les deux hommes
tentent de changer de voiture
un des malfaiteurs est interpellé son
complice reste introuvable
l'ambassade du maroc à beyrouth au liban
mise à sac par les intégristes
pro-iranien ce que l'on appelle le
hezbollah c'est leur répond sans doute
au sommet d'ifrane entre le roi hassan
ii du maroc et le premier ministre
israéliens shimon peres commentaires
bruno albin derrière les fidji
caricature et du premier ministre
israélien est celle du roi hassan ii
affublé du bandeau noir de moshe dyan
c'est d'abord une manifestation de rue
le mot d'ordre a été lancé par le
hezbollah
suivi par environ 15 cents militants
intégristes pro iranien
le cortège se retrouve un peu plus tard
à l'ambassade du maroc les gendarmes
libanais ne sont intervenus que pour
évacuer les grands les gars de marocains
résidant dans les locaux c'est alors la
mise à sac de la chancellerie
évidemment il s'agit de la réponse des
intégristes chiite de beyrouth à la
rencontre d'ifrane ces entretiens israël
aux marocains dénoncé comme une trahison
du roi hassan les slogans des
manifestants des injures et des menaces
de mort au souverain marocain
l'arrestation mercredi à paris du chef
de l'organisation clandestine irlandaise
inla accueillie avec satisfaction par la
police d'hulster la police d'irlande du
nord le chef de l'organisation et trois
responsables de l'hymne appréhendé au
terme donc d'une longue enquête de la
police française qui au mois de juin
dernier avait déjà marqué un point
capital elle avait alors saisi un
camping car bourré d'armes qui était en
provenance de hollande sur cette enquête
et sur le rôle de l'hymne la voici des
précisions avec patrice pollet arnold de
bascher flynn le chef présumé de l'armée
de libération nationale irlandaise elle
des quatre hommes arrêtés hier à paris
flynn à des vétérans de l'hymne là est
aussi un miraculé par deux fois il
échappe à la mort en 82 et 83 dans des
règlements de comptes sanglants à
belfast entre extrémistes républicains
irlandais clean qui s'évade il y a dix
ans de la prison de mèze réputée comme
l'une des plus dures d'irlande en 81 3d
des militants républicains qui s'était
laissé mourir de faim dans cette prison
appartenait à l'inrap
line là qui est né ici à belfast issu
d'une scission avec l'ira
l'autre organisation républicaine linda
qui ont 80 de signe un des attentats les
plus sanglants d'irlande 17 morts dans
l'explosion d'un pub au havre le 11 juin
dernier la police française découvre
dans ce camping car un stock d'armes
impressionnant la camionnette embarqué
pour l'irlande
les armes étaient destinées à l'inrs là
la source se tarit le travail des
enquêteurs a ensuite consisté à savoir
quand les irlandais parviendrait à se
procurer d'autres armes
cela s'est passé hier ils ont été
interpellés au pays basque que
l'attention c'est en maintenant des deux
côtés de la frontière avec l attentat ce
matin contre 1 crs c'était à bayonne
blessé heureusement sans gravité le crs
a été mitraillé par une voiture alors
qu'ils étaient en faction devant le
palais de justice de bayonne
deux bombes ont par ailleurs été
désamorcée gilles bouleau 5h ce matin
une voiture roule à faible allure
derrière le palais de justice de bayonne
un passager jet d'un engin explosif par
la portière
c'est l'explosion de faible puissance la
bombe et et artisanal il s'agit en fait
d'une diversion
alertés les deux crs en faction
s'approchent de leur minibus devant le
bâtiment
la fusillade commence un crs se jette à
terre d'autres est touchée par trois
projectiles de au bras un près des yeux
probablement du 9 mm aussitôt barrages
policiers sur les routes du pays basque
et contrôles dans les milieux
indépendantistes en fin de matinée une
revendication iparretarrak
l'organisation indépendantiste basque
en fin d'après midi à bayonne et saint
jean de luz quelques centaines de
manifestants s'étaient rassemblés pour
protester contre les expulsions de
réfugiés basques espagnols pas
d'incident pourtant mais ce soir au pays
basque
la tension reste vive oui vous souvenez
qu'il ya 48 heures le théâtre militaire
avait annoncé qu'elle craignait des
dérapages en france après la double
expulsion de militants basques et
espagnols faisaient directement à leurs
références aux indépendantistes
d'iparretarrak qui ont revendiqué
l'attentât d'aujourd'hui
reste que le problème ne se pose pas
uniquement en france comme le montre
cette enquête de bruno le dreff les
sentiments anti français sont maintenant
très vif du côté du pays basque est ce
pas
il y à ce qu'il dit et ce qui bronzent
sarah haut sur la côte basque est aidé
ma soeur de l'une des quatre colonnes
qui se rejoindront demain pour une
manifestation contre les expulsions mais
le coeur n'y est pas désormais on trouve
plus de basques sur les plages que dans
la rue
la cause ne fait plus recette sauf pour
quelques militants ce que je pense des
expulsions c'est une attaque scandaleuse
contre les militants nationalistes
basques les réfugiés explique cette
femme ne sont pas des terroristes ils
luttent pour la libération de leur pays
vous avez tort de les expulser pour la
première fois depuis bien longtemps
tous les partis nationalistes basques
ont réalisé l'union sacrée est
unanimement condamné la france
pourtant le parti socialiste espagnol
qui défend la politique française vient
de réaliser réussi son meilleur score
aux dernières élections il n'y a pas de
réfugiés politiques basques
il y avait des terroristes tous ceux qui
n'ont pas commis le délit mais ceux qui
tuent n'ont pas le droit de se cacher en
france votre gouvernement doit aider nos
que penseriez-vous en france si
l'espagne les celi me dit encore se
cacher à barcelone par exemple et y
organiser leur combat si les basques ne
tolère pas la présence militaire
espagnol ils se satisfont dans
l'ensemble du statut d'autonomie qu'il
aurait accordé depuis quelques années
mais ils apprécient peu de voir cette
frontière considéré hier comme un espoir
aujourd'hui faire peur
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée en
allemagne il n'y a pas de victimes ce
sont les bâtiments du constructeur
aéronautique dernier qui était visé un
attentat qu'il faut rapprocher d'une
autre opération semblable
hier à aix la chapelle dans les deux cas
la marque de la fraction armée rouge qui
a menacé il ya quelques semaines de s'en
prendre aux entreprises engagées dans le
programme de guerre des étoiles
américain apparemment les terroristes
allemands sont maintenant passer à
l'action
ce fut l'une des grandes figures de
l'architecturé française fernand
pouillon vient de mourir à l'âge de 74
ans architecte de grand talent
précurseur en son temps mais accablé par
ce que l'on a appelé la sphère pouillon
il ne put vraiment faire valoir ce
talent en france
ironie de l'histoire celui qui fut
dénoncé emprisonné montré du doigt est
aujourd'hui publiquement regretté est
couvert de louanges qui était fernand
pouillon
voici son portrait par jean pellieux un
globe comme celui ci se trouve dans le
bureau de françois mitterrand plusieurs
globes terrestres ou céleste commandé
par le président de la république à
fernand pouillon été offerts à des chefs
d'état étrangers
et c'est à cela que s'est consacré
bouillon ces dernières années à
marseille avec la reconstruction du
vieux-port 1948 il commence là son
oeuvre d'architectes à aix en provence
en 52 il trouve une oeuvre originale
avec une construction de 200 logements
ou les propriétaires deviennent
propriétaires mais 25 ans après avoir
versé leurs premiers loyers dans ce sens
que pour nous vous l'avez vu disons les
pièces sont assez grandes
inquiet le monde tout au contraire les
plafonds sont encore considérés comme
on est un jeune un plus bas à tous a
demandé aux voiliers dans un peu plus
grandes maintenant me dont le grand
ensemble de meudon fait connaître
fernand pouillon
en quelques années il construit cent
mille logements
mais c'est surtout au poids du jour à
boulogne qu'il acquiert sa célébrité est
aussi qu'il sera là la victime d'un
scandale
le poids du jour des souscripteurs une
arrestation une incarcération
mais le scandale est-il seulement sont
faites moyens financiers que nous avions
sans versement préalable
c'était donc une une une tentation
terrible pour les promoteurs pour les
les banquiers qu'ils proposent pour la
grosse entreprise l'entreprise lourde
qui voulaient s'équiper là-dessus et
c'est ce qui a donné dans le fin
chatou vous savez aujourd'hui les gens
semblent avoir oublié cette époque et
les ennuis on avait souscrit nos
immeubles
ensuite on nous aille il demander des
rallonges jolie blonde s'est par contre
bien et puis ensuite finalement s'il est
très peu et le séjour
le vieux l'orientation par
je pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle
conception et qui est encore
actuellement après un certain nombre
d'années on voit que secret fonctionnel
et actuel libéré en 64 il s'exile en
algérie il devient l'architecte
officielle du pays en matière
d'hôtellerie de stations touristiques
les se convertit aussi à l'islam mais
avoue ne pas pratiquer amnistié par
georges pompidou en 71
il peut de nouveau exercer en france son
dernier projet ici le conservatoire de
musique du 19ème arrondissement
en mars dernier on inaugure sa dernière
réalisation le centre informatique du
ministre de la culture à bois d'arcy eu
neuf belles et de son temps des
exigences que seul un architecte de
talent peut concilier ça commence très
bien pour le dernier né de la société
dassault je vous en parlais hier il
vient tout juste effectué aujourd'hui
son dixième vol d'essai est dès à
présent le chef d'état major de la force
aérienne belge donc le patron de l'armée
de l'air de l'air belge vient de se
prononcer publiquement pour l'achat du
rafale enfin en tout cas jusqu'à preuve
du contraire
donc pour le biréacteur français en
remplacement des appareils qui équipe
actuellement l'armée de l'air belle
savoir des mirage f 16 et des mirage
2000 me semble-t-il
en sport la 21e étape du tour de france
n'apporte pas de changement au
classement général les monde conserve le
maillot jaune devant bernard hinault qui
accumule quand même le retard sur son
coéquipier le puy de dôme a été vaincu
par le suisse mechner presque un inconnu
à l'arrivée mais deux vedettes pour
l'accueillir
deux vedettes on voit bien rarement sur
des bicyclettes marque maison d'un seul
en tête au sommet du puy de dôme le
suisse maechler une étape placée sous le
signe de la neutralité le changement
d'aujourd'hui la venue d' homme
politique
cohabitant dans un registre inhabituel
il est quelques couleurs à il est un
maillot blanc à pois rouges et la mayo
et plo à pois lousiane
cette tour voiture propose à rendre à
redire servir les modes non non vous
allez me le dire mais les bonnes ça veut
dire citron vous comprenez pourquoi ils
gagnent les corses et lemond innu une
coexistence difficile qui en évoque
d'eau m'est arrivé dans ma vie à moi
aussi d'avoir pas seulement sur le plan
politique d'ailleurs dans d'autres
conditions my de plaisance et de voile
des solidarités douloureuse désormais
sauf incident dans les tout derniers
kilomètres
le classement général est acquis ce soir
les monnaies maillot jaune avec trois
minutes d'avancé sur celui qui ne
gagnera pas son sixième tour de france
bernard hinault une image dépaysante
maintenant martina navratilova reine
incontestée du court central au profit
de l'amérique vient de nous jouer la
scène du retour au pays après onze ans
d'absence martin a retrouvé son premier
pays
la tchécoslovaquie commentaires thierry
bloch ovationné martina au stade de
stanis chez elle à prague
ému martina avec ce qui n'était pas
possible il ya seulement un an
une balade tout simple avec son père
dans les rues de la capitale
tchécoslovaque ce qui a été terrible ces
dernières années dans ma vie celle envie
folle de revenir ici pas oublier martina
après onze ans d'absence dans son
quartier ou dans la rue à chaque fois
les mêmes gestes d'amitié
les mêmes témoignages chaleureux sans
négliger pour autant ses obligations de
stars sans oublier non plus le retour
aux sources sur les courts de ses débuts
si j'étais né aux états unis je serai
peut-être devenue championne de basket
ou championne de golf qui sait nous au
fond je suis restée la même je continue
même à parler d'échec
le polar de l'été comme tous les
vendredis où la défense et
l'illustration du roman policier sur
fond de parasols aujourd'hui philippe
lefait pascal stelletta honte à coup de
coeur pour un auteur et pour son éditeur
et
non la réponse est non je n'ai aucun de
ces titres à vos conseillers
tout est bon pas de triche encore vous
et moi
fajardie retenez le nom est un copain je
lui envie ces héros de quatre sous née
de son big et de sa désillusion
politique
on lui reconnaît du talent je suis
d'accord pas de triche entre vous et moi
alors un coup de chapeau à son éditeur
du jour neo pour ses couvertures de
petits matins blêmes et un catalogue
souvent inédits le nouveau fajardie
action en 1948 dans une ville du nord
tenu par le parti
un militant communiste ce suicide et
laisse une veuve chapitre 1
à paris rendez vous secret entre le
représentant du bureau politique et le
militant de la confiance chargée
d'étouffer le scandale lui le maire de
la ville en question jusqu'ici membre
excellent du parti notre problème
quatre députés est un petit peu rude
dans sa gestion je connais de réputation
elle est béatrice la femme d'un ancien
d'espagne n'est pas tout pour la mettre
dans son lit
ça c'est chiant regardons des pics
prigent l'arabie taux chômage à
l'adresse et les bars faire là
la contrebande entre la frontière franco
belge du transport du tabac de nelly
chansons de manon les frères autour du
cou qui fit passer en tueur quelle sera
ma mission exacte je vais 36e place
cappel hayes correcte de la situation et
si possible qui va désamorcer les
problèmes
fajardie écrit mais au publi on aime
question de tripes
enfin
lui
sma
qui dit vrai
les festivals de l'été à l'heure du jazz
après salon de provence voici le temps
d'antibes juan les pins c'est le plus
ancien et le plus prestigieux des
festivals de jazz du monde les plus
grands noms s'y sont produits ici
produit c'est encore mais pascal des
chaînes françaises des listes nous
présente ce soir deux musiciens moins
connu du grand public mais dont chaque
concert est en france un événement
retenaient leur nom pat metheny et
hermeto pascual
il est 21h en juin enfin les mordus sont
au rendez-vous du plus vieux festival de
jazz du monde ce soir là ils auront
droit comme chaque soir à deux concerts
en première partie
pat metheny le guitariste doué de sa
génération et qui entre deux tournées
mondiales s'offre deux heures de jazz au
bord de l'eau
nous
que vous jouiez à juan les pins
oui alors comment ça s'est passé c'est
formidable ça faisait un temps fou que
j'avais envie de venir ici il y a un
disque célèbre que tous les jeunes
musiciens écouter du miles davis en
europe 1 enregistré ici à ce festival
alors ça fait des années que je le
connais pour moi c'est un très grand
honneur de jouer ici ce soir
et veut la région est connue dans le
monde entier pour son festival gyan
accueille les plus grands parmi les
grands du jazz mais je ne veux pas le
savoir
à la même heure à deux pas de la pinède
les sonos couvre les solos de me tenir
ici on adore d'autres idoles et ceci est
lui aussi avait hier fois là il y avait
une grande c'est bien ce vin du diable
non enfin oui c'est pas du jazz un fait
pas mal comme nous amener les clients
quotidiens
ce soir il ya quelque chose et ce soir
l'ont deuxième partie il y avait aussi
hermeto pascual venu tout droit des
faubourgs de rio pour un concert pour
une grande fête plutôt que voulez-vous
parce qu elle aime tellement les gens
qu'ils rêvent de se faire 2000 copains à
chaque concert
on
de gauche derrière tu vois je voudrais
voler au dessus du public pour être plus
près de lui
mais je ne pourrai pas le faire à moins
de provoquer un accident
quand m'écrase sur la foule ok vous
calez lui beaucoup de colère
alors je préfère marcher au milieu de
celle oui mon nom pour faire grâce à
pascal le fond d'une parade improvisée
dans les rues logement à 2 heures du
matin les branchés et les bronzés se
sont retrouvés du même côté de la
barrière
si vous aimez le jazz je vous signale la
sortie de ce numéro hors série de jazz
hot c'est la plus ancienne review
semble-t-il de jazz en france jazz hot
donc avec ce numéro hors série
beaucoup d'imagés ou de très belles
photos dans cette photo de jean pierre
leloir en couverture jean pierre leloir
et qui hantent les salles de concerts
depuis et 20 depuis toujours je crois
les pronostics que du tiercé maintenant
les pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé qui se court demain et vous
suggère de jouer le 3 le 10 le 12 le 2
le 4 le 13 le neuf
hélas 3 10 12 2 4 13 9 et as il y a
quinze porte
et puis la météo marine météo à suivre
attentivement en raison notamment des
incendies qui font qu'il faisait
toujours rage la nuit dernière et qui
reprennent peut-être ce soir dans le sud
de la france laurent bouvier
enfin la journée de demain sera placée
sous le signe du plus plus de soleil
plus de ciel bleu plus de douceur et 1 -
mais un - heureusement - devant regardez
la photo satellite près cet après-midi
par meteosat toute la moitié sud de la
france était sous le soleil il faisait
beau presque partout sauf sur les
régions situées au nord de la loire
là il y avait des nuages et bien ces
nuages vont se décaler vers l'est et le
sud-est dans l'aveu dans la journée tant
dans la nuit dans la journée de demain
ils vont se décaler en se dissipant pour
nous donner sur pratiquement l'ensemble
du pays du beau temps enfin du bhoutan
regarder la carte du temps prévu pour
demain du soleil presque partout
quelques risques d'orages deux soirs sur
les pyrénées puis soleil autrement
presque partout quelques nuages que le
petit petit nuages résiduels sur
l'extrême sud est un petit peu plus
nombreux peut-être sur le nord ouest de
la bretagne à la picardie mais quand
même du beau temps attention dans la
soirée surtout en début de nuit
prochaine les ors les nuages et
peut-être même quelques ondées veut
revenir sur les côtes de la manche côté
température et bien c'est la hausse
aussi températures en hausse
heureusement qu'ils redeviennent
normales pour la saison de 20 à 26
degrés sur la moitié nord avec 24 degrés
à paris et de 24-25 jusqu'à 31 degrés
sur la moitié sud 31 degrés sur
pratiquement toute la méditerranée avec
même 30° à marseille pour l'étranger
aujourd'hui nous allons partir aux états
unis demain il fera 31° à boston 32° new
york et 33° à chicago demain
malheureusement en france c'est une
journée de très très très gros départs
l'on va regarder les conseils de bison
futé de la sécurité routière qui vous
demande de ne pas quitter la région de
l'île de france mais en réalité tout les
grands
métropole entre 0 heure entre minuit et
9h plus particulièrement entre 3h du
matin à 9h dans contre 3 heures et 9
heures du matin
essayez de ne pas quitter les grandes
agglomérations on termine avec notre
agenda comme tous les soirs
demain sera le samedi 26 juillet le
soleil se lèvera 6h17 se couchera 21h36
deux minutes de soleil en moins vous
feront les ânes
ce sera la sainte-anne dernier journal
c'est aux environs ce soir de 22h 45
demain c'est philippe harrouard qui vous
présentera les éditions de 12h45 et de
20h de 20 heures elhadi vous retrouverez
claude sérillon très bonne soirée et à
bientôt
e